This world is burning.
And it was you who lit the match
This is personal.
You're the most wanted man
on the planet.
My mom always said I was special.
Hi. Samuel L Jackson,
acclaimed actor of stage
screen and innumerable credit
card commercials have worked
with countless artists, but rarely
am I gifted with a scene partner
that glows with such talent
as my co-lead in Marvel Studios.
Secret Invasion,
The one and only Ben Mendelsohn.
Ben is a true master of the craft,
and it doesn't end there.
He's also an acclaimed cellist, a champion
archer, and an esteemed scholar.
I can truly say that I'm a better person,
having met
what the hell is going on here?
But despite no attention to this, I was
just talking about how good it is work
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.
This'll be my Secret Invasion Episode
4 Trailer Video.
There are bunch of Easter eggs
and references here and paying off
some of the big cliffhangers
from the end of episode three,
so we'll break it all down.
if you're bringing new to the channel.
I'm doing videos for all the episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get them.
And we're doing the Disney
Plus giveaway for memberships.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and post your favorite moments
from the trailer on the video,
careful for spoilers
from the end of episode three.
If you haven't seen it yet,
just because we have to address
the big cliffhanger first.
So obviously Emilia Clark's character
seems like she's that we know that
she's alive because she's alive
and all this later trailer footage
from later episodes,
some of the trailer footage here
is probably from episodes
five and six as well.
but what really happened to her character?
Like,
how did she survived that gunshot wound
it just based on the footage
during the trailer here some early theory
is that she actually gave herself
super Skrull powers before this moment
and we'll get a flashback
at the beginning of episode four
that will explain that
they might start episode four with her
just healing the damage the same way
the gravity, like he healed his knife
wound, John Wick style
when he pulled it through the knife
because he has Extremis powers
revealing that he'd already given himself
Super Skrull abilities.
They'll probably do something similar
for Emilia Clark's Gaia character,
where she's just lying there
with the gunshot wound
and it just slowly heals itself
and then they do a flashback
to show you what really happened
when she was escaping.
And they'll show you her
activating the super skull device,
because you see
that happening in the trailer,
Like she's actually
pulling all these levers
in there
being surrounded by this big light.
there was probably a moment
when she was in the process of escaping
after she stole
the information, gave it to her father.
They stopped the missiles
and she was running out of that base
in the way they cut. Episode
three during the end there.
They just showed you her outside of
the facility after she'd already run out.
this is like a little missing time period
that they'll probably flashback
to during the early part of episode four.
way. Oh, by the way,
I have super small abilities now,
in the comics,
Super Skrull was only one character.
But on the TV show in the MCU here,
they're all becoming super skulls,
or most of them
are becoming super skrulls,
at least the way
the gravic talked about it.
They would all get
all these different abilities.
So not just one of the abilities.
So Extremis just gives them the ability
to auto heal all that damage
There also a lot of rumors early on before
the series came out that Emilia
Clark would get special powers.
That would be kind of like Abigail
Brand's powers.
And I think
this is what they were talking about,
remains to be seen how they manifest
all the different abilities
because the only ones we've seen so far
are the Extremis abilities, which looks
just like the Extremis abilities.
During Iron Man
three in during the trailer
we see gravic using his Groot
like super skrull abilities.
so within the next couple of episodes
we'll see them use those other powers
and just see what
they actually wind up looking like.
But my early theory right now is that
she winds up taking her father Talos
place as Nick Fury's right hand person
with all those extra powers and becomes
kind of like an MCU version of Abigail
Brand with similar types of powers.
just because
all these different references
seems like they're pointing towards that.
Like he's already on the space station,
even though they're calling it
the saber space station,
not the sword space station.
Like the comics, Abigail Brand manages
that in the comics it.
If you remember early
on, before the series came out,
there was some fan art.
People thought that she might become
a version of Abigail Brand
just because it seemed like
she could look like a version
that character to be pretty cool.
Pay off Now it seems like they're actually
going to do something like that.
Not the way that people expected,
but pretty similar.
but the whole idea is that she's not dead.
She's totally back.
Like she was never in any danger of dying
when she got shot.
And she was just trying to trick
gravity gear.
He also played in totally understand
how the Extremis powers would heal her
that way.
place will wake up from the damage
after gravic has already driven off
thinking that she's dead and be like,
Oh wow, I'm not dead.
This is great.
that's also why
I think they had that gravic scene
with the knife in the National Gallery
where he pulls his hand through the knife
so that you see how Extremis Powers work
for casual viewers
who don't remember Iron Man three
or didn't watch Iron Man three.
So they don't know what Extremis is.
sort of like a
tutorial in how Emilia Clark's character
could survive that damage day,
that funny clip of Talos doing Skrull,
Nick Fury again to pump himself up.
A lot of people also wondering about there
being another Skrull version of Nick
Fury during the series, like a skrull
that thinks that it's
Nick Fury in the real Nick
Fury is doing something totally different.
We'll see about that. It's
totally possible.
Like there will be a twist
within twist within a twist.
And I think that will try to pull that
by the end of the series.
Like there are couple twists
with Skrull, Rhodey, like, oh,
wow, he's been a Skrull for a while now.
How long has he been a skrull
there's kind of a big twist
but a twist within a twist
would be revealing that the Nick theory
that we've been following
this whole time in the series
is also a skrull
Like what would the real Nick Fury
have been doing this whole time
these past couple of episodes?
this is also a riff on a comic book idea,
like comic book
Secret Invasion and just comic book
skrull stories in general.
skrulls that have been pretending
to be characters for so long
that they forget who they really are
and they start to think
that they are the real person.
there's a very dark
twist on the very first skrulls story
in the old Fantastic Four comics.
So the screws come from the fantastic
Four comics.
That's why there's so many Fantastic
Four Easter eggs in the series.
but that very first skrull story
ever, like when they debuted in the comics
for the first time,
ended with Reed Richards
brainwashing a bunch of skrulls
to think that they were really KAOS
and they just live the rest of their lives
thinking that they were real.
KAOS later
comics actually brought the gag back,
but paid it off in a really dark way,
saying that those skrulls were later
butchered because the farmer who owned
the cows thought that they were KAOS,
so sent them to the slaughterhouse
like regular beef cattle.
when they were slaughtered
in the slaughterhouse,
they reverted back to skrull form
and were ground up into strong
beef patties that people ate all over
the United States.
really gruesome ending to just
a funny joke from the classic comics.
but I wouldn't be surprised
if there's a skrull
that they revealed during
the series has been pretending
to be an Avengers
level character for so long
that they just forget
that they're really a skrull.
They think that they're the actual person.
But it sounds like based
on the end of episode three Skrull, Rhodey
definitely knows that he's a skrull
like he specifically references gravic
when they're talking to Nick for his wife.
No, no, no. You're not talking too
gravic. You're talking to me.
net. The big question about that to people
wondering
what's going on with Nick Fury's wife.
So it could be that she's just trying
to talk to grabbing her surrogates,
not like she thinks of gravity
as her surrogates
and she's trying to talk some sense
into him as a mother would to a child
it seemed like
she took particular interest in him
as a child when she rescued him.
So it would make sense that she become
like his surrogate mother in Nick Fury
as her husband will become kind of
like his surrogate father.
And that's why he has such
a personal relationship
with Nick Fury in with his wife.
they wanted you to wonder, though,
if his wife had been working with Gravity
since the snap,
because she did say that
she started becoming
more like the person she was before
she met Nick Fury
after he'd been snapped in Avengers
Infinity War.
some of the trailer footage here
has her fighting with Emilia
Clark's guy, a character.
So it does seem like she is good
in helping Nick Fury's side and all this
there's a scene of Nick Fury
going back to his gravesite
where it says Nicholas Jay Fury.
The tombstone may have been created by
his wife after he got snapped in Avengers
Infinity War. And that's why
there's so much growth on it.
grabbing his eyepatch and his weapon
is meant to be a parallel for his wife,
grabbing her gun out of their safety
deposit box?
will probably wound up happening,
though, is that after everybody came back
after the Hulk snap in Avengers
Endgame in after Iron Man's funeral,
he probably put his eyepatch
in his weapon in here just as a backup
and then went to his saber space
station, Ben.
There's a much bigger attack on
what seems like the president's convoy,
like a big pitched battle with gravic
and the super skrulls Nick
Fury and Talos trying to stop them
that could be from a much later episode.
Skrull Rhodey is here too.
They want to make you think
that they're trying to kill the U.S.
president.
Then we see Gaia cradling Talus.
Her father looks like he's
been injured badly in about to die.
So it could be that they're using this
to set up her taking his place as Nick
his right hand person.
you can let me know in the comments
if you think they'll kill Talos off
because people really do like Ben
Mendelsohn.
He is really good as the character.
a couple days ago I also post that
Fantastic four Doctor Doom video.
It sounds like he is a hardcore Dr.
Doom Stan as well.
he definitely knows his comics.
if he hadn't already been playing
the Talos
character for a long time in the MCU,
I would say
he'd actually be a solid candidate
to play MCU.
Doctor Doom, one of the big things
those are using Secret Invasion
to set out this Marvel Phase five Dark
Reign era, where Thunderbolt Ross becomes
president of the United States
like villains
start to take over in there, giving him
sort of the Norman Osborn storyline
with Val from the actual comic
book Secret Invasion.
what might wind up happening
even if they don't actually kill the U.S.
president during this?
Is that thunderbolt?
Ross just wins the next election
because Captain America forwards
when he's supposed to become president.
So we're still a little ways away.
but they could just explained
that Talos is trying to win over humanity
by proving
that some of the skrulls are good.
He could try to do that
by sacrificing himself to save the U.S.
president. it.
It might wind up getting broadcast
all over the world news where people see
Skrulls sacrificing themselves to save
humans like oh they're not all bad,
but I think part of the idea
is that a lot of people play on people's
fears, like, Oh, who is this girl?
Who can you trust Thunderbolt.
Ross sort of steps in to fix things,
quote unquote, like the Thanos.
I'll do it myself kind of thing,
where there's a huge backlash and people
want more security, more safety.
And he provides that like he rules America
with an iron fist in battle,
so to speak,
doing all kinds of shady stuff
that's more of the Earth based Marvel
Phase five, Marvel Phase six, plot
all the space based stuff.
That's all. Fantastic
four X-Men Mutant related stuff.
Kang Multiverse War, Avengers
five Avengers six.
there's another scene with Nick Fury
going to the super small device,
having a fight with gravic there.
Then there's another scene
with a bunch of agents
coming for him inside this building.
Not clear where they are,
but these might be the President's men
or just other damage control
agents thinking that he's the villain
because of something else
that happens during the series.
when he has another meeting with Skrull.
Rhodey,
it seems like he starts to suspect him
more like, Oh, you're probably is Skrull.
Like, maybe he calls him
Nick a couple more times.
Nobody calls me Nick during that
he also says Tick tock and he says he's
the most wanted man on the planet.
It just sounds like something winds up
happening and Nick Fury gets on the radar.
The president's Men in Skrull.
Rhodey tries to use that against him
because obviously he's trying to help
Braddock.
there's a bunch of other big reveals
that they have to make.
There's supposed to be a couple
of really big surprises
in the last couple of episodes,
so put all your theories
in the comments below.
But my full episode for video
will post next week after they release it.
in a couple of big things
that just released.
I'll try to do videos for everything
as quickly as possible
everyone click here
for my full Secret Invasion
Episode three video and click here
for that Spider-Man
Beyond the Spider-Verse Teaser
Trailer and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!